good boy
okay hun ready
we're heading back to Camp with the wood
we Forge
all right perfect we made it through the
first tank no problem but now we want to
make the site a little more comfortable
so we'll use the wood to build some
furniture so we could make it as much
like home for the kids as we can we'll
have to build a lot of things like this
when we live off grid so it'll be good
practice for all of us
look honey we're home
this is so relaxing actually I need to
have this all set up and I know look at
West sitting up though eh sitting all
the way up on his own he's not even
leaning well good job Wes yeah we're
talking about you doing so good since
Wesley has been diagnosed with Fox G1
syndrome it's been reiterated to us with
pediatricians with other Specialists
that bringing Wesley out into nature
exposing him to some elements the better
it will be for his development
Wesley's core muscles have really
strengthened up a lot hey Tori yeah big
time yeah just from him sitting in the
canoe I bet and just having to keep
stable there yay I'm going to be making
Furniture should I make a table or
chairs first definitely a chair chair
what are you gonna sit on
just kidding
right now I am building a couple chairs
I'm just taking four pieces of wood and
making two triangles one of these
triangles is going to be a seat and the
other triangle is going to be a backrest
I've always thought it was interesting
to try to make stuff for yourself ever
since I was a little kid
it's always fun to see what you can kind
of make with your hands with the
materials around you as opposed to
always relying on store-bought items
before we left home Jim and I made a
high calorie Trail food called pemmican
it's made from dehydrated berries bison
meat and rendered animal fat
I'm adding it to a stew with some
veggies it's the perfect high nutrition
meal after a long day of hiking and
foraging this is all just kind of
practice if you will for when we are
going to spend much more time at an
off-grid cabin that hopefully we can
build maybe in the near future
yeah like that
like that
Tori
ready for a chair but crafted by the
hand of the man of the Wilder Jim Baird
himself
that's nice enough for that champion
booty of yours or what
huh
should I test it out
yeah there you go
I'm scared no it's good oh yeah it's
kind of a lean backy feel you know I
like it yeah I like this
look at mine hon huh look at you right
ah oh this one is great too
that is comfy look at that that's a joke
good job honey good day crushed it
[Music]